it's a new chapter in Tanzanian politics
[Music]
opposition parties are celebrating the
end of a seven year ban on political
rallies
thousands of members of the main
opposition party chadema marched in the
streets of Monza on the Southern Shores
of Lake Victoria in Northwestern
Tanzania and gathered at a sports
Stadium to Mark the occasion
[Music]
we have faced mountains of hardships and
fought for 30 years some of the parties
decided to compromise the government but
we interdemon stood firm we are proud to
have built an institution that could
fight for our rights to have a new
Constitution and all other needed
reforms in our country
the ban on political rallies was imposed
in 2016 by then President John magufuli
his successor Samia surulu Hassan lifted
the band two weeks ago as part of a
broader set of reforms but also warned
against violations of Law and Order
since coming to power in 2021 she has
introduced limited reforms including
lifting a ban on pregnant girls
attendance at school and launching a
covid-19 vaccination program
opposition activists expressed relief
but say more reforms are needed they are
calling for a new Constitution that
guarantees more political freedoms
we thank the president for the decision
to allow political rallies so we can
exercise our constitutional right now we
expect the police not to side with the
government
now we need the new constitutional
reforms and free and fair elections the
Constitution we have now does not favor
the political system we have
[Music]
Tanzania is preparing for civic polls
next year and a general election in
2025. opposition parties are promising
more rallies and demanding better
election laws to guarantee that those
are free and fair Mohammed